MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this section, we'll
look at tracking detectors.
And before we look at tracking
detector technologies,
we want to remind ourselves
how we measure the momentum
of a charged particle.
And this measurement is possible
because charged particles are
reflected in magnetic fields.
We have already seen that in
a homogeneous magnetic field,
a particle follows a circle.
And so from the
measurement of the radius
and the knowledge of
the magnetic field,
we can infer the transverse
momentum of the particle.
Typical particles also have
a longitudinal momentum.
And so therefore, the
trajectory is actually
of the form of a helix.
And so we then can get
back to the total momentum
of the particle by knowing
the angle or the component
of the longitudinal
and transverse momentum
and then just calculate
total momentum from there.
So we have seen
that particles, when
they go through a piece of
material, that the energy loss
through ionization
or bremsstrahlung.
And so what we have to do
now is put some material
in the way of the particles
without really changing
its momentum or
changing its trajectory.
So this is typically done
with tracking detectors.
And so what you then measure is
not just the radius directly,
but you measure
individual points
that's part of the
trajectory of the particles.
And so from the
measurement of the points,
you can then reconstruct the
trajectory of the particles,
and then therefore
measure the curvature.
And that has been
used to measure
the transverse momentum.
So if you look at
this picture here,
the radius can be given as L
squared over 8s plus s half.
s is typically called the
sagitta of the trajectory.
If L is much, much larger
than s, it simplifies to r--
about L squared over 8s.
And the uncertainty on the
sagitta the uncertainty on s,
is limiting the uncertainty
on the momentum measurement.
And this is described
in a paper which
is very nice from the '60s.
And the formula is called
the Gluckstern formula.
So what you see here is that the
more measurements you actually
perform along the sagitta,
the better your measurement
is performed.
And this goes with
the square root of 1
over the number of measurements.
The total momentum uncertainty,
or the relative momentum
uncertainty, sigma
pt over pt, is
proportional to the
uncertainty in the sagitta.
And that also is then
proportional to the pt
of the measurement.
So if you want to improve your
measurement of your momentum,
you want to decrease
the uncertainty,
then you can do this
by having a larger L--
and you see this goes with
the square of the length--
you want to increase
your magnetic field,
and you want to reduce the
uncertainty on the second term.
Those are the elements
you have in play in order
to improve the
transverse momentum,
or the momentum measurement
of your charged particles.
So this is a screenshot
of this paper.
The measurement error
is not the only error
on the transverse momentum,
as we discussed previously
already.
Multiple scattering, so the
scattering of the particle--
and it goes with momentum--
also reduces the uncertainty
in the momentum measurement.
And we can show
that this component
on the relative momentum
uncertainty is flat.
So what you find typically is
that the transverse momentum
measurement is limited by, at
high pt through the measurement
error, and at low pt
through multiple scattering.
We have those two components
entering the measurement
uncertainty.
So the actual detectors,
I just give you
a couple of examples here.
The first one--
and the first one,
which actually really has
allowed us to make measurements
with a lot--
devices with huge
statistic experiments where
you have colliding
beams, and you
look at many, many
of those interactions
was a multi wire
proportional chamber,
at a reasonable resolution.
Typically, we have
hundreds or thousands
of wires with a spacing
of up to 1 millimeter.
And this 1-millimeter
spacing in a wire chamber
limits the spatial resolution.
If you don't have any knowledge
of where the particle was
in that area, then the
uncertainty of the spatial--
on just one hit,
uncertainty is given by d,
the spacing between
those two wires--
1 millimeter in this case--
divided by square root of 12.
So you find typically
resolutions of 300 microns
per measurement.
But you may gain off the
fact that you typically have
many, many, many measurements.
And as you just saw, this
reduces the uncertainty
on the measurement.
You knowing that there
was a hit on a wire
gives you two-dimension
information.
If you then built
the wire chamber such
that there's angles
between individual wires,
you can use that
in order to gain
three-dimensional information
in the geometry of where
the particle went through.
Wire chambers can be
operated in different modes.
And it depends on the level of
voltage you apply on the wires.
So the higher the voltage--
the level of the
voltage goes down here,
see a very limited voltage
applied, then the ions--
you have ionization,
and the ions
recombine without
being collected.
In ionization mode,
you collect the ions.
And there's typically
a gain factor of 1.
You measure each ion,
basically, separately.
You can increase the voltage
and run the wire chamber
in proportional mode so you
have a gas multiplication
factor so the ions
are being accelerated,
and then they produce many
more, more ions to be measured.
And you typically have gain
factors of 10 to the fourth.
If you drive this
further up, you
go into the limited proportional
mode, and then in Geiger mode,
where basically you
have an avalanche,
and so you have no information
about the initial ionization
anymore.
And typically, the
chamber breaks down
and needs to recover afterwards.
The signal formation is
quite an interesting concept.
So you think that
you do ionization,
the electrons are there, and
then they're being collected.
Yes, that's true, and this
happens very rapidly, typically
in the order of nanoseconds.
But the actual real signal
comes from the ions themselves.
And so what happens here
is you have your wire here,
you have your electrons.
The ions then themselves, they
build this cloud of charges.
And this cloud of charges then
gives you a signal on the wire.
And this happens
typically via influence,
or you basically have a mirror
charge on the conductor.
And that is really where
the bulk of the information
comes from.
We just discussed that the
spatial resolution is limited
by the spacing of the wires.
You can actually get
better measurements
by using the timing information.
If you are able to measure the
time profile of your signal,
that profile has information
about the distance
between the ionization
and the wire itself.
And that then helps you to
improve the resolution further.
So I really don't
do justice to this,
but nowadays, specifically
in high dense--
particle-dense environments,
you use solid-state tracking
detectors.
And they're used in many, many,
many areas in particle physics.
The idea is to use
mostly silicon,
but you can use other
semiconductors as well.
You dope them, meaning
that you create
more holes by using p-doping
and n-type doping for more
electrons.
And then you bring n-doped and
p-doped materials together.
And you-- you know, it's
the same way as in a diode
in that then you apply a
voltage in the opposite way
to create a very
large depleted zone.
So in this depletion zone,
there is no electrons
and no holes available.
But when a charged
particle travels through,
like is shown in
this picture here,
you create electron-hole
pairs, and they then
can be used in amplification
to create a signal.
That's the general concept in
which solid states or silicon
detector [INAUDIBLE].
The nice thing about
silicon detector
is that you can read
them out with very
fine spatial resolution.
So from this 300
micrometers we just saw,
you go down to
several micrometers
in spatial resolution
when you measure particles
going through the detectors.